and
uh uh just
to kind of connect to
yesterday this was r view that I'm going
to take in this talk in this in these
two lectures basically we are thinking
about algorithm High dimensional
geometry
from sorry there is some delayed the
sorry uh okay uh through the pris of
nearest NE search and you know again
this is kind of a choice I mean like
different different prisms could get
different results or would highlight
different results and this is this a
personal choice but you know how I view
it and uh there are you know what I'm
trying to focus on on particular ideas
or particular techniques kind of and um
so yesterday we talked about Dimension
reduction and space partitions and today
we'll cover several more ideas one of
them being small Dimension number is Su
Bings and sketching and later I'll talk
talk about you other
things okay
uh so let me start with small
Dimension right so uh you know High
dimensional geometry but you know what
if Dimension D is small right uh so you
know what happens then right so again
the goal let's say is to solve nearest
NE search okay so um th out we can solve
1 plus Epson approximate nearest number
search we essentially near space and
query time that depends exponential
Dimension right this is um you know
something I mentioned yesterday so you
know there is a bunch of
work how to solve this and uh you know
it is okay if say Dimension is really
small okay uh so you know if probably
you know even if you plug five here it
it doesn't look very favorable but you
know at least in practice it kind of you
know makes sense kind of it it works for
Dimension which is small like
510 um okay so you know good you know
but usually Dimension D is not small so
you know this data set for example has
700 plus
Dimensions um so know what do we do
then um so you know one can you know
kind of push it harder and say what if
Dimension D is effectively small you
know for some notion of
effective uh so here is one very simple
example so suppose our um Spa our space
is D dimensional D is very high but the
points that we care about really like on
a low dimensional Subspace thank you no
it's fine um thank uh so it's on K
dimensional sub where K is much smaller
so suppose five dimensional right so
then you know obviously you know you can
just focus on that sub space nearest
there and it's effectively low
dimensional situation just good uh but
you know first of all this is not a
robust definition so you know if you
think in any kind of reasonable kind of
practical setting you know your your
points will be slightly perturbed there
will be some noise so them lying on
kensal Subspace is really not it's just
not real right it's too too non
robust so but you know kind of following
this idea but you know let's define some
effective Dimension there have been
proposed a number of definitions of
Dimension what you know like slightly
more robust definitions what it means to
be effectively small dimensional and U
some of them including a dimension
looking at things like doubling mention
which I'll mention in the next slide
things like you know manifolds which are
lower dimensional and which are smooth
and so forth okay so let let me you know
let me really you know focus on ding
Dimension explain what it is and you
know see what what happens okay so
definition so the definition is for a
particular set of points S I really
don't care about which space it comes
from and I say that it has dation
Lambda if the following holds um so
consider a point P so you know let me
just do it by picture so we have some
point set we take any point P we take
any radius R we take the ball of radius
R around p and now we say that this
point set has Dimension Lambda for any P
and R we can cover this ball by two to
power Lambda balls of half a
radius okay so I it measures some kind
of growth of a metric right um so this
is definition and kind of you know for
any kind of definition but tries to
generalize something else you know it's
good to do some sanity check and check
that you know it corresponds to the all
definition that you kind of you know the
way you expected in particular if you
take K dimensional Subspace of a very
high dimensional space you want it to be
of you know this doubling Dimension to
be roughly K right and this is true I
mean if you if you take some Subspace
Dimension K which is essentially just K
dimensional real space take any ball any
radius you try to cover it by balls of
half radius you know it is you know
classic geometry to say that this is
covered by you can cover this by
something which is exponential in the K
number of
BTS
okay you know POS check one another
thing that is you know also good to kind
of check is that if you have n points
there you know end points any bolt is
always coverable by end points by end
boltor this means that Dimension this L
Dimension is always bounded by Logan so
this kind of corresponds to the
intuition that we have from John that
you know any point set should be
effectively at most log and dimensional
right because we can with very small
loss in approximation can reduce to log
and dimensions so essentially any end
points you know maximum Dimension should
be Logan and this is what it says right
for any end points the dimension will be
at most LAN again okay so this is the
definition very cool part about it is
that doesn't use any ukan geometry or
anything I mean the definition at least
right so it works for any metrix space
can you find it for any metrix space
okay so you know assuming this Dimension
so we have a point set suppose it has
small doubling Dimension what can we do
well it turns out that you know we can
do some you know better nearest number
search effectively as if it is if it
wear KY dimensional space so so one
particularly nice example what I like is
from a paper by who said that okay
suppose we have a doubling you know
Lambda so Point set of doubling
Dimension Lambda in ukian space so
there's you know a little bit more
geometry uh so then you know very cool
part is that if you just apply the
dimension reduction the J St that I
mentioned yesterday you can just apply
it on this point directly and you can
reduce into Dimension K which is order
Lambda and you project it there randomly
and this
works okay so you know this is kind of
you know one of the other applications
of D of Dimension reduction um so you
know find it very cool so what does it
mean to work uh so you know we won't
prove that for any two points this uh uh
the distance is very high concentrated
just because we don't have enough K but
uh what you can prove is the following
that if you consider contraction so
contraction means the distance you know
decreases VI this map a lot uh so this
is called contraction so you can prove
that contraction of any P any pair of
points from this point Set uh won
happen with basic contraction happens
with very small probability of any
pair expansion on the other hand can
happen with a constant
probability okay so we don't have a you
know very good distance approximation
guarantee for any pair of points but we
have these two uh these two uh
guarantees right and what is you know
cool about these two guarantees is that
this is exactly good enough for nearest
NE
search right uh because contraction of
any pair we don't want that any of the
far points right which are kind of not
good answers to come any closer to our
query Point uh just a second and uh we
don't want that our actual near neighbor
goes too far away right and in some
sense you know this has happened to has
to happen for all end points this has to
happen for exactly one point so it works
there's a
question
yeah exactly so this is this is exactly
the point that I guess so far I se try
to to convey but it works for the
purpose of nearest number search
so what happens in particular if you
look at what happens for two particular
points right they won't contract with
very good probability something actually
for this the entire set of
points the contraction won't happen for
all the payers with good
probability it won't it's not going to
preserve distances pairwise for
everybody right it's just that it has
asymmetric guarantees it it says
something stronger about contraction
than about expansion and this is ex
the kind of trade of what we need for
nearest neighbor
search right you don't want the far
points to get close and there are many
far points so this has to happen very
good probability on the other hand the
expansion meaning that the actual near
neighbor expansion means the near
neighbor you know the one point that you
care about for the particular query that
we have goes far away this is expansion
but and we need to guarantee expansion
for just one point the near
neighbor
okay
contraction means two point the distance
becomes smaller
what
um yeah if you look at any particular
two points but if you take an entire
Point
set I mean the proof is not simple
proof I mean can take it offline but
yeah I mean this is this is exactly kind
of the cool part of it right I mean that
you know it almost looks magical
so it's approximate approximate it's
approximate so sorry I meant to say that
all algorithms are approximate that I'm
talking about so but I mean you can get
one perception
approximation okay and uh you know so in
some sense you know like once it's good
enough for nearest neighbor search you
reduce to essentially effectively
Dimension Lambda and then you apply the
low dimensional nearest neighbor
search and uh you
can
um uh you can uh you can do this also
for bit metric sorry just to answer your
question I mean think about K
dimensional Subspace right if you do
projection into order K if you do
in order K dimensions then you'll
preserve the distances for all the
points entire Subspace infinite number
of
points it's it's just that in some sense
you don't have to argue about end points
you effectively can discretize them and
say you take some form of Epsilon net
and say but I have to only talk about
exponential in K uh points so this is
this is how a proof would look like for
contraction for expansion it doesn't
work uh I can go later in detail okay so
for arbitary metric there are you know
very cool algorithms basically
navigating Nets from c g cover trees
from uh belgar zimer kadian Langford um
and um you know essentially the
algorithm you know just kind of give
high level description it is essentially
you know data dependent uh recursive
tree that partition the space
recursively into bowls and um you can
think of this like partitioning theace
SP rather than you know using lines as
we were doing yesterday we are
partitioning them using
balls um and um the algorithm is
slightly different in the sense because
it actually achieves linear
space the query time is exponential in
the dimension Lambda um and this comes
roughly because you know rather than
following Just One path down the three
as was yesterday we will follow several
paths down the tree which essentially
corresponds to all the paths uh you know
this of this recar partioning that
intersects the ball around Q of you know
particular radius r that we care
about so I mean I you don't mean to
describe V in detail I mean it's
somewhat similar at least in spirit you
know from the perspective of this stock
from this high level perspective is you
know somewhat similar in spirit to uh to
the partitioning algorithms from
yesterday okay so you know this is small
Dimension um so basically you know the
the point here being that you know you
can um you know if if you really don't
like high dimension you can you know
redefine your dimension and you
hopefully that uh hopefully the data has
some more structure and it is
effectively behaves as a low dimensional
space and then you can s solve nearest
neighbor search as effectively as if it
were low dimensional space and of course
this notion has appeared in in many
other contexts and um and you know show
that's many other algorithms for example
are solvable as if effective Dimension
is B Lambda as opposed to high dimension
okay and uh here we come to Second uh
second idea or topic of today which is
edings and this is really a very big
field um with lots of connection to
function analysis um so there is a lot
here I'll just you know probe you know
some places of this really big topic um
but you later I'll mention what you know
what things I didn't
cover Okay so so you know it's you know
general theory you know has so basically
you know big topic has you know big
motivation um so you know kind of you
know just again taking a step back and
saying okay so in general you know so
far we mostly talked about ukan space
but uh and Heming space but you know
General we have many other metrics and
ways to measure similarity or
dissimilarity between objects right um
and um you know and you know this is
what we call distance or a metric M uh
and uh you know there are different
computational problems that we want to
solve under this metric M uh so you know
I mentioned Hing distance youing
distance but the other things like edit
distance between two strings that I'll
mention later or F mover distance or
Transportation also called Vin distance
um so these are you know form of
distances or metrics uh and you know
there are different problems in
particular was F focusing on search but
you know in general there are even such
basic questions and Computing distance
between two points or two objects from
this metrix sometimes this is a hard
question um or diameter closed pair
clustering Min spanning three and and so
for right um and general you know so
what what do we do right so you know we
already know some metrics like Heming
distance cing distance where some of
these questions are simple you know
Computing distance for example is you
know simple right just linear you know
comput it directly there research and
we've been focusing so far and kind of
tried to convey but you know in some
sense you know there are solutions you
know maybe there are not the best yet
right but there are some very
non-trivial solutions that you know get
you somewhere and we'd like to get this
for other metrics and you know what do
we do you know kind of very
computational scientific uh
computational science uh computer
science approach uh to hard problems is
you know first approach is to try to
reduce to simpler problems that we
already know how to solve right um so
this is the picture that you know like
oh we'll try to take some hard metric
you know let's think of this as hard
metric um you know some Ma and reduce
into something simple right which is
this is kind of Manhattan metric right
um uh so the idea is to map kind of a
hard metric into simple
metric uh in a particular so that we
reduce a problem under a hard metric for
example nearest search under F distance
uh into simple problem which is you know
a problem under a simpler metric say
your search under Heming
distance okay so this is General view um
and uh This Is The Brute Force approach
right uh that we' like to be able to to
do but doesn't always work
um so
uh so you know let me Define this
formula what is what is an aing so an
embedding you know for formally is a map
from metric M you know think of this
like hard metric into host metric H uh
which we think about it as being a
simpler metric such that for any points
X and Y from the original one the
distance you know row H this is the
distance in the new matric of the
projected of the of the maps of the
points is approximated up to factor D
which here it is called Distortion but
think of it as an
approximation okay uh and you know
obviously if you manage to so so this is
you know this is a reduction but of a
particular sort right it says that okay
maybe we can take all this hard metric
and reduce it into a simpler metric and
then all problems that we can solve
under H we can also solve under M you
know assuming that this Roy is nice and
this D is
small yeah yeah up to rescaling off row
right I mean if if metric H has natural
rescaling internal rescaling you know
which usually does
then you don't need to assume that but
yes in general you know sometimes it
doesn't happen in general you would put
some Factor you know Z here and here
right so so it doesn't matter right so
for example nearest Amber is still
preserved up to approximation D for
example okay and uh you know again you
know this is big Theory there is a lot
of types of embeddings first of all you
know they come in all shapes and
colors uh so first of all you know what
you map from which am into which host
you know what is the Distortion that you
can get these things can be
randomized so for example you would
achieve this guarantee only with some
probability uh another question is you
know what time does it take to compute
this function for example and you know
like for different variants of this we
can you know all kind of
metrix all kind of embeddings for
example you know something that we
already seen is dimension reduction
where we say we take one Norm say ukan
space and we map it into the same space
but of lower
Dimension
um and um you know there is another you
know another type is from one nor to the
other it turns out that you know
essentially the same Pro that I showed
for Dimension reduction actually works
to prove that you can embed ukan space
into into Manhattan space Heming space
um the other type you know kind of photo
I was trying to allude to on previous
slide is that you can try to embed nonn
Norm spaces um things like edit distance
or distance into a norm like Al one um
different way is to you know another
type of of embeddings is to say that
rather than talking about General spaces
I'll take a particular end points and a
particular distance definition of these
end points so might not have any
geometry whatsoever and I'll try to
embed into L1 right or maybe you know it
has some geometry like it is the
shortest path on a planer
graph um and uh you know this will be in
the in the next section but you know
sometimes H is not even a metric okay
all right so you know this is kind of
you know General overview just to you
know you know suggest what kind of
things do they exist uh but let me you
know what I want to to tell you
essentially you know one particular
embedding just to give you a flavor of
how these things work so basically what
we want to do is you know map hard
metric into simple matric but we already
know how to solve for example or you
know for which we have efficient
algorithms so here is one metric you
know which is not a simple metric and
you know it's still kind of you know
there are many parts of it but we still
don't know how to do
efficiently uh so it is it is a metric
defined on sets Okay not on points but
on sets uh so we have two sets a and b
um in some underlying metric space so
this is say green points and and red
points and the distance between the
distance between these two point sets is
just the the cost of the minimum
matching right so this is also called B
chromatic mean cost
matching um okay so which what is the
underlying metric space well it can be
just two dimensional plane as you know
the picture pictured here but actually
it can also be higher dimensional uh um
and you know this is actually
something you know higher dimensional
kind of underlying metric space
sometimes has applications in image
Vision so you know just to just to
explain to you um uh so these are you
know pictures of my alma matter um which
is probably hard to recognize uh unless
you've seen it before uh so um the idea
is that you know yesterday I mentioned
that you know you can take image and you
take it as a bit map and kind of compare
Direct
and you know that's you know as you
probably might have guessed you know
it's not exactly the best way to measure
the similarity or the similarity between
images right so some of the mod methods
would say that well let me take you know
two images to compare let me extract
some you know key point or some Corners
some particular points that I that you
know seem very specific to the image so
I'll I'll Zoom onto them I I'll extract
them and I'll represent each of these as
a high dimensional Vector now
and uh what I say that you know my cost
the dissimilarity between these two
images is the earth mover distance of
this cloud of rectangles versus this
cloud of
rectangles
okay so you know this is the
definition and now you know how do we
solve nearest neighbor search under such
a
matter
right and um so you know what we'll do
we'll embed The Sur M distance into L1
into head in space to incur some
Distortion but you know we we do what we
can uh and you know before juming into
embeding you know first of all why into
L1 for some you know one of the reasons
is that at least as hard as
L1 um
so takes a couple minutes to think about
this but you know it is at least you can
embed uh L1 into EMD essentially so you
can represent
any uh basically Hing space into in
Earth distance so you know it is not
simpler so can only be
harder uh and here is the type of you
know theorem that you know you would
prove for for embedding uh so is that
you can embed Earth distance over say
two dimensional grid of uh with Delta so
this is integer grid into
L1 I won't specify Dimension
um but it doesn't matter that much um
with Distortion which will be
logarithmic in the size of this
grid okay and you know good point is
that time to embed will be kind of
small
um and you know why do we why do we care
we can this immediately implies nearest
NE search in particular we'll get
something like Cogan
approximation
with this much space which is you know
sub quadratic space and sublinear in N
the number of sets qu
time okay I mean this bounds don't
necessarily look particularly nice but
you know this is the type of things that
you get um think of this as you know
this is basically the description of a
set so this is just you know how many H
tables we have and this is just the
effective dimension of this of the sets
Okay and uh but I mean some sense this
this doesn't all all you know
just give nearest neighbor search it
also gives you know uh other artifacts
like Computing Earth distance so even
Computing a distance is between two
point sets is not a simple task and it
is only very recently um as of a year
ago that uh there is a approximate near
linear time algorithm to compute it
right but before that essentially the
best algorithm to compute was more or
less uh by getting this log Delta
approximation by V Vis eding right where
you would just take the point set you
embed it into L1 and then it just
compute the distance between these two
edings uh and actually you know there is
a higher dimensional version of this uh
where you don't you know it's a high
dimensional grid and uh for that variant
of f distance Computing the distance
between two such high
dimensional clouds of points is you know
the best way we know the best way we
know how to do it is via this embedding
so embedding to one and then compute the
distance between the
embeddings okay and um you know in the
next a few slides I will be proving this
embedding yes
so you said briefly that there's now an
algorithm that does that you can compute
DMD quickly yes this
one approximately approximately yeah it
yeah it's a non-trivial
algorithm um so yeah I mean this is
stalk 2012 result right before that it
was the best linear time algorithm would
get constant approximation it was
essentially using this type of
ideas okay all right so um okay so let
me you know so this is a high level
overview how the imping roughly looks
like uh just you know to show that you
know in the end even though the proof
will be somewhat you know complicated uh
the actual embedding looks very simple
so so we have sets of size s in this
Delta by Delta box this is the Box uh
and suppose we want to embed a set a
right so this function takes each set
embeds separately right we know the
embedding the embedding Works set by set
um so uh here is the point at a so what
we do we take a quad threee we randomly
shifted so imagine this is randomly
shifted and uh now each cell of this
quadry will give a
coordinate um and this coordinate you
know in the embedding corresponding to
cell c will just count the number of
points in that
cell right so basically there will be a
bunch of coordinates but for example for
coordinates corresponding to Vel Vel Vel
and Vel will have values 2 two 0 1 1 Z
okay so quatri is actually recursive so
think of this is you know recursively
partition Quarry and we'll have cells
corres you know we'll also have
coordinates corresponding to cells of
smaller cells so you know you can
compute exactly in each cell how many
points there are and it will be you know
a bunch more coordinates we just compute
the number of points in each
cell and this is V
building right I mean just starting with
the right by3 and and the right number
of levels and everything U and log Delta
really comes from these log Delta levels
okay because this is this is the the
number of levels that you'll have in quy
with partitions this this Delta by Delta
box okay and if you have you know
another blue blue set you know you can
compute the same and you know it will
give some other embedding right which
looks like this right just to give
another example so this is the
embedding uh and essentially what one
can prove is that you know if you have
these embeddings
then there is a randomization not that
there is randomization because of
randomly shifting this quadry uh so what
want to improve is that the expected L1
distance between these embeddings for
any for any points A and B for any sets
A and B we
expected uh expected one distance
between the embeddings where the
randomization is over this random shift
is approximately equal to distance
between A and B up to log Delta
approximation um so you know this is you
know what I'll try to kind of show and
uh you know let me kind of you know how
to go about this proof you know uh so
here is here is one kind of General
approach to proving this statement uh so
in general we can view this uh you know
each level of quat in particular the
highest level of quatri as partitioning
recursively the EMD into smaller grids
so suppose these are our two sets right
so so we're just proving the statement
for any A and B the expected L1 distance
between the bendings is roughly equal to
the F distance between the point sets
Okay this is this is the claim to prove
so consider this points A and B we have
this random uh random Quarry so we we
can think about it as as uh
partitioning uh as being
computed you know as a sum of two
quantities one quantity one type of
quantity is f m distance on each uh
smaller
cell
right uh plus F distance on kind of meta
scale okay so you know essentially you
you take something you know big big
um uh big box you partition in two parts
and then you say that oh my f distance
you know like the way to view about F
distance between two point sets is to
see what happens in each small thing
plus a high level
view um okay and what we'll do we will
recursively we will recursively reduce
this so essentially uh so what we've
just done here is we composed F distance
over a Big Grid into F distance into
smaller grids and then you'll take so
for example each of these grids and the
composite
F okay and this is this is a point of
view that essentially what the embedding
does um and you know in Logan Logan
iterations will be down to grids which
have say constant size say
3x3 okay and just to you know see what
happens if F distance is really kind of
on a small grid say 3x3 then uh uh say
suppose you know it is really 3x3 then
you know just
counting the number of points in each in
each of the nine uh
locations and you know taking this as an
embeding so basically we have a
coordinate for each of these uh each of
the nine locations counting the number
of points if this is the
embedding this gives constant
approximation right
because you know if for any points which
are in the same location it's better to
match them this cost as
zero and for any unmatched point for
example here so we can match the red to
blue which will cost us zero so there is
no loss we can just you know essentially
erase these points you'll be just points
at these locations that are unmatched
say this red one and it doesn't really
matter where we match them because any
matching to anything except here will
cost us you know somewhere between one
and uh
say root two root sorry root
um I mean it depends exactly what is the
V underline whether it is ukan distance
or it's Manhattan distance which doesn't
really matter because this is two
dimensional
space
um okay so you know basically so we
count the cost of matching in this 3x3
grid is really the number of of points
of essentially the disparity of number
of points in each of the grid locations
and this banding is counting exactly
this okay so you know the point being
that you know once we reduce to grids of
small size say
3x3 when we are done you know we get
constant
approximation okay so so basically what
you know what I showed you this is kind
of a base case of russion right what I
want to show you is the inductive step
in some
sense uh um so this is a decomposition
Lama uh due to
indig uh that you know essentially
proves this high level view that we take
a Big Grid we decompose it into a bunch
of small grids plus a high level Grid
all right so this is the high level Grid
and these are kind of smaller grids so
there is one thing that I should mention
that
uh you know we'll talk you know this is
what this second e stands here
uh it stands for extended uh F distance
uh the idea being that uh you know once
we start you know something that I
didn't mention from beginning that what
happens if the point sets have different
cardinalities um right so it is it is
not well
defined so this extended distance is
essentially a way to define essentially
Define way with this issue um and uh it
will say that
uh uh so if we have a and b say and say
size of a is bigger than size of B then
this extended Earth distance uh will be
basically mean cost
matching uh of uh a subset a from a
where uh size of a is equal to size of B
so this will be mg between a prime and
B
plus essentially the extra
points times essentially
max distance in
Grid I mean this is kind of very natural
extension saying that well the points do
not match then all the points that you
know are left unmatched we will will pay
the maximum possible distance right this
is like in Bart right if you lost your
card then you'll pay the maximum trip
cost right um okay so
um so this is I mean there are two parts
usually to these things proving you know
we want to prove that this is
approximately equal right so this means
that we need to prove an upper bound and
a lower bound right so this is a lower
bound because it says that this will be
the new cost
right so this is the comp like one step
of a decomposition where we say the cost
of you know these emds plus the cost of
this EMD is approximately equal to the
original EMD between a and b and these
things corresponds to the cost of this
essentially you know one step of in
Banning uh and so this A1 B1 are
essentially corresponding to uh sets uh
restricted to V cell this is set
restricted to V cell and so forth right
so this is this sum plus this part
corresponds to F distance between uh
kind of high level
view okay so high level view is
essentially should mention uh before is
that high level view says that uh we'll
have a a point alocation for each of
these cells and it just counts the
number of points in in this cell right
so this is what this Big Grid is right
this high level view right as if as if
we' taken this cell and contracted into
just one point okay um and the right way
to compute this uh the the cost of
distance here is that we will
um you the right scaling is to multiply
this by K what is K the K is uh the grid
length of of this uh this sound
okay so think of this you know if this
is this is Delta then K will be roughly
Delta by 3 right if we really partition
into into just uh free 3x3 grid okay uh
roughly speaking you know why do we
multiply here by K because matching a
point say from here to
here should cost us something
proportional to the length of the grid
not uh not one so this is you know if we
if we have if we if we have something
mismatching at a high level you know
corresponding to this kind of meta grid
then any mismatch in a high level
picture should cost us much more than
any Mis match at a local
scale so this is where this Factor K
comes
into so so this type of inequality is
essentially lower bound on
cost mean there is an also an upper
bound on cost which you know is kind of
the opposite um the opposite inequality
and uh here on upper bound you know one
can actually do this upper bound
separately saying that the cost of uh
expected cost of Earth Mover distance on
on this local view essentially on each
of these uh grids smaller grids
separately so the of these costs is
upper bounded by essentially F distance
between original sets and also again
this the second term of the cost
basically the the cost of matching the
points in this meta grid uh is also uper
bounded by the original F distance cost
between A and
B okay and you know just to just to
repeat the the Distortion will will
apply uh By You Know by applying this
the composition recursively for L log
Delta
levels uh so you know let me kind of
give you know hints of proofs uh of
these parts um so part one the lower
bound basically this is what we want to
prove that this extended distance on
original points a and b lower bounds the
cost of matching in each of the cells
separately plus the cost plus know the
scaling Factor the cost of matching in
this meta into meta grid and uh you know
so think about this inequality kind of
what you want to prove and what do you
need to prove you want to you know in
general we want to lower bound this
quantity right so this is what we care
about but one can view this slightly
differently and say that well what I
want to do is I actually want to show
that Earth M distance between A and B
can be upper bounded by this which means
I want to construct an actual solution
for f mover distance that achieves at
least at most this cost right so I want
upper bound I want I won't exactly
compute what is this AR distance between
A and B but I'll show some matching
between points a between sets A and B
that whose cost is upper bounded by
this okay so essentially what I'll do is
say Okay Suppose there is some cost for
doing this right this is the cost uh for
matching you know this uh F you know
decomposed kind of f m distance uh and
what I'll do is I'll exract some
matching from these from these things
that will give me a cost uh of matching
a b you know bounded by
this okay it it need not be you know the
optimal cost but you know it is it is
upper bounded by this okay and how do we
do it I mean basically this you know the
general intuition is that this uh F
distance already give us some partial
match there so they they already give us
some matching right and we will just
extract a matching for the entire Point
set by completing what happens right and
essentially you know there will be stuff
that you know appear here but
essentially you know the inition is
really simple it says that okay I want
to match point andb right I I matched
somewhere inside these Point sets and
then I'm done with those points or if we
are not matched here then we are in this
extraneous part right this unmatched
guys right and these unmatched guys will
be matched this means that they should
be matched at high level somewhere and
for them we'll pay K this is really the
intuition all right so again you know
just pictorially so okay suppose we have
some point we want a point from a we
need to match it to somebody um so some
red point we we match it to some blue
point and you know if you can match it
inside here then okay this will come
from the cost of matching inside this
cell but for somebody for something that
is extraneous right for which we'll pay
kind of the M the max grid length well
essentially um you know it is it should
be
matched uh it should be matched on this
higher level Grid right at the course
level because we will be you know the
number of points do not correspond here
right so this is extraneous point so it
will have to be matched in this Big Grid
and in this big grid for example it is
matched to you know some other points
from another
grid and this is
paid this is you know you don't even
need to read this right but you know
intuitively this is paid out of this
cost out of matching it at the high
level okay uh and again I mean don't
need to follow the details of the approv
I just you know really want to kind of
give you the flavor of the type of kind
of Flor bonds that
uh the flavor of how these embeddings
work
usually
um so uh I mean by note that so far we
have not you know at least to prove one
inequality we have not Ed the
randomization right so we have to use it
somewhere and we are using it on the
other side in the upper bound
side in particular saying
that the expected cost of ing
inside um inside each of these grids say
a 1 B1 and uh is essentially upper
bounded by the cost of matching uh sets
A and B and also the cost of matching in
the this course level Grid meta grid is
also upper bounded by this in
expectation
um so you know the type you know the
proof will work this way uh so fix and
matching
um I mean we have to somehow connect to
the optimal solution here right so we
need to use in our proof saying that
this can be upper bounded we need to
somehow use what is the optimal Solution
on left hand side on this on the best
matching between sets A and
B uh so let's fix a matching Pi that
minimizes the Earth over distance
between sets A and B
right so this is just bomatic matching
and we will construct the matchings for
f distance on the right hand side so
suppose this is the optimal matching of
the sets of the two sets uh so now we
have imposed a randomly shifted grid and
what happens right so here we want
to match each of the um I mean in in the
lower in the lower level grids we we'll
have to do matching here and then here
and so forth so for this part at least
uh the matchings you know we pay these
green Parts which are fully inside which
are not cut by uh uh by the Quarry so
basically the pairs of points A and B
that are under in this matching Pi if
you are if they have not been cut by the
by the Quarry then they can be matched
inside each cell right and they will
appear in this cost
uh the main problem so in some sense you
know there is no harm done by by this
quat uh the the main problem is that
sometimes harm can be done by quad three
in particular if it begins to cut uh it
manages to cut some pair that has been
matched so if there is a pair AB that is
that is matched under this optimal uh um
matching Pi
then its cost will appear uh
um it it cost will appear in this you
know meta level Grid right
um and and the the cost that we'll have
to pay will be roughly proportional to
the length of the
grid to this
K and uh the problem is that you know
you would expect that you know this
happens only for you know intuitively
say like oh if the points are far away
these points the the points A and B
are far away this is this is the case
when it will be cut right so this is a
very Co level Grid right I mean this
distance is very large say right this is
say a third of the entire grid size
right so it's saying that well if if the
two points are very close you know we
are unlikely to be matched they unlikely
to be cut right so it should be fine
right so it it is only the pairs of
points that are far away but will
probably be cut by this grid right so
this is a good intuition but it is not
absolutely correct because in
expectation it can happen I mean it
could be that there are a lot of Point
pairs of points that are
nearby so their distance is small but
just a a fraction of them will be cut
essentially by kind of by expectation
that there are just a lot of them at
some moment some of them will be cut by
this Big
Grid uh right that
was completion of a picture but you know
points that are
they have to be matched in the Big
Grid and uh so this is really the the
last slide of the of the analysis and
we'll be
done uh so you know just to finish this
this part that you know what happens to
this cut edges right what is the total
cost that we pay for the cut edges and
um you know again the uncut payers a are
matched in in the smaller cells so in
some sense uh we we have the same cost
on the left hand side and right hand
side so the main the main problem comes
from a pair that is cut by the uh by
this metag grid and uh here is you know
one computation that kind of very often
comes in this kind of embeddings um it's
very similar to the kind of space
partitioning type uh type analysis that
you know have seen yesterday but if you
have a pair of points A and B and
suppose we are so we are two dimensional
suppose the distance on X and Y is DX
Dy so if they are cut then the
contribution will be roughly
proportional to the length uh to the
side length of the of the Big Grid uh
which is K uh so this is how much it
will contribute to the cost that we are
trying to Upper bound and uh and now you
know the question is what is the
probability that for a point which has
DX and Dy here here uh basically
difference on X is DX difference on Y is
d y what is the probability that they
are
cut and uh you know it's a kind of
simple calculation that the probability
that they are cut essentially this which
can which is upper bounded by the
distance uh by the distance between a
and b and divided by
k um so you know not going through the
calculation the idea is that the
probability that a point or that a pair
of point is cut is proportional to their
distance is proportional to their
distance divided by
K and if this happens when we are paying
something proportional to K to this grid
length so the expected
contribution so I mean this K which can
potentially be a big
factor um goes
away so we expected so you know while if
if it is cut right it can pay it can be
very small distance and if it is cut
then it has to be matched in this course
level Grid where it will pay a lot right
K you think of K is large but the
probability that a small Edge is is cut
is exactly inversely proportional uh
with K so the expected
contribution from this will be just
proportional to the to the length of
edge
maybe so
when so this is the main kind of
intuition of what's
Happening um any so just to wrap up all
this ining invent you know you apply
this recursively you will obtain that F
distance between sets and B will be the
sum of f distance of smaller grids in uh
in expectation you repeat
it log Delta times until you you get
down to very small grids and you get log
Delta
approximation just because you have log
scales okay so this this really was kind
of you know the most technical part of
of the talk so from now on it will be
more much more high level
um so okay so this was an embedding
right uh so what else can we do right so
you know this is just you know one
particular embedding people have thought
about many more edings so here let me
Focus kind of on two types of metrix
actually right uh again so these are
kind of f mover distance so this is you
know what I just showed you um this is
there is like difference that this is
you know log in the set size essentially
um the same Bing roughly uh you know one
can do it even on sets over High
dimensional spaces um but it's also you
know a bunch of work for example only
baning Ed distance what is Ed
distance it's you know just classical l
metric between two strings which says
that how many insertions delions do you
need to do to transform one string into
the other so for example between banana
and ananas which is Latin for pineapple
um is
uh uh is to right you delete B and
insert s here at the end right so it it
uh it it measures kind of for example
the um kind of M type uh it measures a
form of dissimilarity between strings if
you think about the error model as being
the number of uh M types that one does
uh it's actually kind of more used in in
uh computational biology where you think
about say comparing DNA strings where
insertions dels seem model the mutations
possible mutations and there are
different types of ID distance for
example um the classical distance um you
know that you probably all know from
interraction to alth class you know can
be eded say in L1 with this much
Distortion so this is somewhere between
logarithmic and and polinomial um so
somewhat better uh results are obtained
for edit distance if it is restricted to
be edit distance between permutations so
think of this as you basically the no
character repeats twice kind of
situation which you know for example
measures some some distance between the
rankings for example um Blog the
distance and you know the general pict
here is that you know this is this is
kind of good right I mean we are getting
logarithmic approximation you know
except this this case especially we kind
of can get logarithmic approximation by
bending into1 and for all these for all
these metrics essentially this means
that we can get nearest neighbor search
with parameters like in ukan space or or
Heming space except that you know the
approximation is higher is of this
sort okay uh so this this is schol um
and you know here's the natural question
is can we do better right why not um so
it turns out that one can prove
nonability
results proving that if you want to if
you want to embed you know what is the
best Distortion best approximation for
Banning in 121 but can actually prove a
lower bound and say that well the best
you know you can only achieve so much
and this type of lower bounds do not
care about Dimension so
uh irrespective of the target Dimension
kind of if you want to end in 121 you
know many of these things will get uh a
lower one which is
logarithmic
okay okay all right and uh let me kind
of you know indicate how this non
bability results look like uh so these
are form of isoparametric inequality
so in general you know proving nearest
search lower bound as data structures is
you know is a hard
question uh and uh so so these type of
Lor bounds are you know more geometric
kind of statements so we are talking
only about metrics they don't talk about
computation right and um so we're very
similar we essentially in nature there
are some form of isoparametric
inequalities uh and you know very often
we are proven VI are what is called P
type inequalities and let me show you
how this P type inequality looks like um
so by this you know let me State a you
know very classic theorem by nlow which
says that if you want to embed say
hemming cube of Dimension D into ukan
space of any Dimension then you must
incur Distortion which is root Dimension
root
d okay so if you ever wondered whether
you can you know do this ending of of
hemming space into clean space then the
answer is no unless you incur very high
dimension which is
Rudy and how roughly the proofs looks
like and you know this is you know like
at least the outline of a proof is
inspired by uh by for analytic
lowerbound VR cot now uh so you know so
what do you do you you kind of prove by
contradiction you say suppose f is the
embedding you know f is some embedding
of of this hemming Cube into ukia space
um so usually go around proving such
lower bounds by constructing two
distributions over pairs of points and
think of this is uh one distribution is
over close pairs of points or edges uh
for example you take a random Y and X is
just one random coordinate
flip right so this is this is a
distribution on pairs of points and and
think of this as close because these
pairs of points are very close to each
other are distance one another the other
distribution is essentially over far
points or diagonals uh where you take
say X and Y are random in this situation
you know why call me a far because we
essentially incur the maximal distance
which is Omega
D and the proof goes we two steps in one
step you're saying you know essentially
this intuition that one is Clos and
another is far but the expectation of a
distance over Clos
pairs is upper bounded by order D
of sorry it should be one / D
um uh of the far
Pairs and
um part two let me just modify this
quickly
okay this is the right one um so
um yeah basically we saying you know
this are short on the other hand we're
saying but if under this map F you know
that we hypothetized that
exists uh the the edges must be long
right I mean we we we prove a lower
bound of Omega one/ root D essentially
you know this type of claim is also
called short
diagonals right so so there are two
parts right I mean one saying that you
know in the original metric this you
know the close things should be really
close and far things should be really
far uh and in the Target metric what
happens is that you know one way to see
it is that diagonals have to be
short
okay and uh you know this type of claim
for example you know cut short but you
know this is very simple to prove by
essentially writing out this function in
in for an analytic basis it's a few
lines
proof
um and uh note that you know basically
for these two things to to live together
this means that function f has to have a
distortion of root D okay okay and but
you know this is a general type of of
lows I mean a lot of these nonability
results look like this I mean you find
some distributions and you prove these
two
steps okay question
yeah so yeah let me show you you one uh
oh you sorry you didn't understand which
part how the second statement is proven
right so the second statement is so here
is actually this is what en proved um so
in equan space for example if you have
four points any four points when the sum
of diagonals is upper bounded by the sum
of
edges so this is I mean this is kind of
like the type of geometric things that
one would
prove so it's with Distortion let's say
capital D right so now where is capital
D should appear in this last
line uh no no no no so this is you know
note that F appears both here and and
here what it essentially says is that
any set of so take take our Heming Cube
under this function f it Maps into some
two to power D points in thean space so
there is some inequality which really
use this is the geometry of your linean
space uh that you know some linear
inequality on the distances between
these two points between sorry these um
two
quantities uh so to complete the proof
for Dimension is
um what what you'll do is uh you
know so you have this EC on you know F
you say that this is at least Omega
uh Omega 1 / root D of expectation over
far Pains of this F stuff right and uh
essentially now you're using that you
know if
F uh has some Distortion so suppose f is
uh uh non-contracting then this would be
expectation over close of the original
distance right and this should
be at least expectation
F over
original times some
Distortion let let put Distortion
here
sorry
right yeah sorry one over root D here
right and for these to live together
with these inequality we need to set uh
D to be uh root uh root
Dimension right so these are two
inequalities that go different ways
right
okay uh so you know going forward you
know
okay so these are lower ones in 12 one
um we we can take this offline question
if Ian if it's still confusing okay uh
okay so uh so okay you know L1 is one
host space right I mean can we Ed into
some other host spaces where we can do
you know good stuff uh so what is a good
host space uh one is that you know
should be algorith tractable basically
you know it it's not it's not file to
embed into something that is hard right
we want to embed some somewhere where
say we have good near NE search and two
is it's Rich you know it's we can embed
into
it uh so for example you know basically
yesterday we've seen that you know foran
space or Hing space we can do you know
good enough nearest research
unfortunately you know just indicated
that you know we are not rich enough to
to be able to to host these spaces with
very good Distortion right so there is
logarithmic L Bond so one can consider
some other things where you know
variations of this L2 L1 where you know
they are still logally tractable for
example one can consider essentially the
the space of point of real space so
Square del2 let's call it where we have
real space with distance which isan
space Square
right so you know this essentially means
that we have roughly the same nearest
neighbor search maybe you know up to
squares in in distortions and
um you know it is it is richer you know
it gives us more power than a 12 and n
one right uh unfortunately it is still
uh it's still not rich enough so you
know for this kind of uh you know at
least for this type of metrics later on
you know we've proven that
uh you know by there are something that
is called communication complexity that
I'll mention a bit later that you know
essentially this kind of lower bound
still hold even for these more
uh more general or slightly richer
spaces so you know there they are
slightly richer but they are still not
rich
enough okay so then the question is like
okay what's next right and
um you know so here you know I should I
should I should save the Infinity story
um so this is something that is uh on
other kind of end of the spectrum where
it is Rich so so Infinity story this is
a norm where the distance you know real
space the distance the two points is the
maximum difference on the coordinates
right so it is another distance you know
so so you know think of this as as an
aside uh what happens here so the really
interesting part here is that you can
embed any metric on N points into an
Infinity of Dimension n
exactly uh so you know this this sounds
like good right I mean it's it's really
rich right and uh okay we also need
nearest NE search for this right and I
didn't mention it before but uh there is
a very nice algorithm that says one can
solve nearest neighbor search for for L
Infinity with approximation which is
double logarithmic in
dimension so I I won't dwell into this
but uh but you know this is what is
known so in some sense if we can embed
into an
Infinity then we're pretty good right
and uh the problem is that you know if
we have end points eding into Dimension
n is not really good right so if only to
take our point and to embed it will take
time n then you know all the
improvements on nearest SE just do not
make sense right you take linear time in
your data set just to map your point
into Infinity right so the question is
can we do this with smaller
Dimension right so we say okay you know
you can embed end points into an
Infinity of Dimension end maybe there is
some Dimension reduction result or
something maybe we can directly embed
this into a smaller Dimension the answer
is that you know for some spaces we can
actually embed directly into infinity
and use this type of result to get good
nearest search things like house DF
metric but in general it is not possible
and it's not possible even for for cube
so if you take a
cube uh a 0 1^ D then to embed this you
know the the dimension that you need to
embed the entire Cube will be roughly
exponential in
D
so uh so you know to kind of uh to
conclude kind of this this discussion is
that if you want to embed into low
dimensional Infinity then it no it is
algorithmically tractable but it is not
rich
enough you can embed into high
dimensional Infinity which is Rich
enough you can embed anything into it
but unfortunately it is not
algorithmically
tractable right and this is kind of you
know the
setting uh and uh the cool part is
something um something that I find
surprising is that combination of these
things sometimes works much better than
each part separate l so this is the type
of thing where say the sum of components
is much more than uh the combination of
components is more than the
sum um so okay so let me kind of you
know show you you know one such
combination uh so meet our new host this
is how it looks like uh and you know
what it is is really kind of combination
of L1 L infinity and
L2 squared uh and each is of low
Dimension um and you know what does this
combination mean is you know think of
this as you know L1 is just you know
standard L1 metric what is L Infinity of
L1 think of it as your your points are
now matrices of Dimension 2 x two uh to
compute the the distance between two you
subtract the matrices you know Point by
point you take one Norm of each row you
get a bunch of numbers you take L
Infinity of the of the resulting numbers
right so this defined C Infinity of L1
now you can go a step further you can
Define Square all two of you know
composed to this so this will means that
you know now we have this sheets of
matrices so we have three dimensional
thing right and you know basically you
you know you do the obvious thing uh you
first do L1 then infinity and then you
have a bunch of numbers you take L2
Square which is you know the sum of
squares of
differences uh so this is some you know
crazy looking uh norm and
so you know generally call it iterated
product
space
uh so you know what why you know why
shall we care about this crazy thing uh
well because we can uh uh and what we
can is uh two things one is that we can
embed say ulam uh ulam metric so ulam is
just Ed distance implementations into
this thingy with constant Distortion
constant approximation
uh where each of Dimension with Alpha
Beta gamma is proportional to the length
of the string of the original string and
part two is that uh we can do very good
uh you know nearest neighbor search well
reasonable nearest neighbor search in
particular you know there is a result
saying that for any T iterated product
space basically T is free here let's
say two depends how you look at it but
you can get a log log n approximation
with near linear space and sublinear
time so you know the type of result that
we are getting for nearest number say
for haming space and uh you know just
combining this together this means that
you can obtain nearest number search
Forum with log log N squared
approximation and uh the you know just
just to repeat the point is that for
each of these components
separately I you know L1 or L infinity
or Square L2 of the corresponding
Dimensions there is a logarithmic lower
Bound for ending into each component
separately so somehow combination of
them gives you much more
power right so essentially this says
that you know this type of iterative
product spaces are rich and algorith
tractable so you know as you can see
these are like you know relatively
recent results so you know still not
necessarily fully
absorbed
um uh so okay so you know I'll mention
that slightly later again but you know
here we're coming to essentially uh the
stoping which is
sketching
um uh which you know essentially you
know already the previous
um you know this this type of you know
combining this uh these Norms together
and getting you know something more
powerful should already kind of Le to
the idea is that like well you know how
far can we go and you know maybe the the
distance that we compute at the end
doesn't need to be very structured like
L1 or L2 but maybe something more
General
so basically this is sketching can be
viewed as a more computational view on
these embeddings so what happens is that
you know embeddings we said that we have
some crazy space there we embed into say
haming space or clean space uh VI are
this map F and this map you know is um
say approximating approximates the
distance and after this map where you
know maybe Computing the distance
between X and Y was hard after we do
this map Computing here the distance new
distance is very easy so nule space you
know is this formula right so you know
the sketching says like well rather than
doing this you know according to
concrete formulas kind of how about
plugging in a computational procedure
right so which will take essentially
these f ofx embeding f of x well f of x
and F of Y and then apply some
computation and this computation will uh
will give us you know a distance or
approximation of original distance and
uh just because we're talking about
computational things you know it's more
preferred to think about this not as
real space but you know something that
is has a number of bits right uh so this
is this should be kind of more kind of
correct definition of what it
is and uh you know of course this comes
with pros and cons I mean this is
something more General so first con you
know first downside of this is that
rather than you know previously we were
mapping into Sayan space we had a lot of
structure once we map into something
that is you know of this as
computational space we have much less
structure now right
um so you know have to be attentive uh
the proc is that you know we have more
Express ability so perhaps we can obtain
better better approximation or smaller
Dimension
um so uh and this can be seen also as
you know functional compression scheme
um interest of time let me not go into
that uh so why in general I want to you
know
so there are you know three reasons to
do
that one is that uh we can
do uh we can do more than what we could
do with
embeddings uh so you know this more
accessibility
helps uh part two is that uh it's
actually a way point to get embeddings
so not only it is I mean more
expressible but it it is you know it
helps to think about it uh even if we
want to get embeddings and part three is
that the theory of sketching connects um
the very beautiful theory of
communication
complexity
okay
um so it turns out that uh I have uh
less time with slides
um so let me
uh I uh so I'll have to skip some of
them uh so one you know part for part
one the point being that we can do the
maity reduction into
L1 uh by doing this these sketches uh so
the type of results you know it's very
similar to Dimension reduction in nuan
space so we have a linear map into log n
by epon squared Dimension except that at
the
end after this map we do not compute a
one distance as what a real Dimension
reduction would say we do some kind of
computational
procedure and how this map looks like it
it looks exactly how I suggested
yesterday it should look like we are
multiplying X by some uh Matrix where
each element is is chosen from one
stable distribution which is koset
distribution you know essentially you
know L1 version of gaan distribution
this is distribution and this
computation procedure rather than taking
say one Norm of this takes
Minon this is your computational power
that you gain and then you can
proveo
your sorry yesterday is square s yeah
because we're carrying about L1 now we
car sorry L2 right now we're carrying
L1 uh so points to about sketching is
that uh it is actually way point to get
in Bings right so in fact you know just
just coming back to this embedding into
into this iterating product spaces so
the cool part is that you know this kind
of embedding was really obtained as a
essentially geometrization of some
algorithmic procedure so there are some
algorithms for computing ulam in more
local way you know some nice
characterizations but actually came from
you know the field of sublinear or local
algorithms basically property testing
and streaming algorithms and uh you know
Vis Banning could be seen as essentially
geometrization of this right so so one
had to take this
characterization essentially think about
this as a form of low dep circuit that
you know maybe at you know at the
beginning would do some kind of sums
between certain things right when the
infinity then this uh sum of squares and
uh you would represented distance
between permutations as this load up
circuit right so this gave you kind of
computational power and then you take
this this computational procedure and
you would geometrize it essentially
represented as Computing some kind of
norms um so this is how this roughly
looks like sorry for skipping it uh I
just want to mention that uh finally you
know all all this theory of sketching
has connections to communication
complexity and uh what is communication
complexity communication complexity is
the old of Alis and B right uh so how
many of you have seen communication
complexity oh okay um not as many as I
thought um so this is uh something
introduced by y 79 it is a a
communication model where we have okay
Al Bob uh we have some inputs say X and
Y um and we have to solve some problem
right for example for us the problem
would be you know given some Metric we
want to distinguish whatever the
distance between X and Y is smaller than
r or bigger than approximations times R
so communication complexity is a much
more General kind of type of problems
right I'm just uh making it particular
for us and it's two part two- party
protocol basically what what happens
here is that uh these two players uh are
communicating transmitting bits and
we're actually counting the number of
bits and we need to solve this
problem right so I mean one way to do it
is for Alice to send entirely X this x
to Bob and Bob would compute it uh
exactly but this takes too much
communication with try to do it in much
less Communication in
this um you know just to make sure this
is shared commun we have some shared
Randomness um and sketching is really
you know it's it's a simplified form of
this communication where basically Alice
and Bob produce a sketch of X sketch of
Y so think of this is this big f of x
big F of Y we send it to referee and the
referee looks at this sketch runs this
computational procedure and essentially
computes
it uh computes the answer and the good
part is that you know so this is
something that has been
studied uh
so uh in particular there is very rich
theory about it I mean there's no way I
can list all the papers here so think
you know introduced by 79 there is a
book about it
um uh and uh
um so there are some notable examples um
I I'll have
to so I'll skip them
um uh at least for video we'll be there
um but uh so there are you know people
have thought about this for for standard
Norms um this um you know has very good
connections to near S search um has very
nice connections to imped ability and
there are still questions that open uh
and uh I I really kind of you know allow
myself to skip it because I I I hope
that Graham corod will talk more about
sketching and communication
complexity um and uh streaming
um so one thing that uh you know I
didn't talk is there are things that I'm
not covering here um again you know if
one were to take a different prism would
see some other things um so again uh
sorry for skipping this so I wanted to
highlight a very cool algorithm by Greg
valant for for closest paare which ises
Matrix mation to beat what we could do
previously with lsh type
algorithms this this is the description
of the entire algorithm sorry for
scheming it uh I just want to just uh
give a you know say a few words about uh
this slide in particular things that I
didn't talk about and there are a lot of
them and one of the big things that I
that I skipped in this talk is about
embedding uh you know a big part of
embedding Theory where we talk about
embedding um fixed finite Matrix maybe
with some structure into Norms like L1
and this is very very useful in
optimization questions for questions
like spares card uh so first of all I'd
like to point out the paper of linear L
rabinovich who essentially introduced
the metric embeddings to F computer
science literature and they showed that
one can use uh what is called called
Bain LMA
um uh which appeared in functional
analysis literature to solve spares scut
with Logan approximation so spares cut
is you know is an optimization question
uh and you know there is a bunch of
other results
that showed that different forms of
embeddings are useful for optimization
questions um and there is you know
there's actually a very good um document
with open questions collected over the
years by jik
and that is the link and uh let me just
finish you know essentially with uh
concluding what we have seen um in these
two lectures uh so what we have seen is
high dimensional geometry seen through
the prism of nearest neighbor search and
uh uh we in particular we've seen you
know a bunch of ideas uh several you
know what I view as core ideas at least
from this prism uh so yesterday we've
seen Dimension reduction space partition
and today we also seen you know what do
we do you know can you redefine
Dimension what if the data set has
effectively small dimension in Bings the
theory of reductions between different
metrics and Norms sketching the more
computational view of embeddings and
there is much more that unfortunately I
didn't have uh time to cover thank
you so we do have time for a couple
questions question there so wonder where
there are simulation study to show all
your order calculations actually P up in
in real
simulations I'm worry about the
constants in front of your ERS right so
some of the algorithms you know more are
more practical than others right uh or
some are more impractical than others
right uh so in particular the embedding
for f distance that I showed is actually
practical and people have implemented
and run it right and even the high
dimensional versions uh are very similar
to what is called pyram mid match kernel
um so I mentioned the name there so
there's a few people from it I me moved
on um so including people like chrisan
growman and Trevor darl who used that
kind of edings to construct better
indexing for for for image
search um but you know some algorithms
do have you know bad constants that are
not practical so some of you know for
example Ed distance at the moment I do
not see you know the things that I
mentioned not practical fortunately but
I mean maybe these are just First Steps
Ian more need to be done other
questions in most of the things that you
mentioned today and also yesterday U
maybe accept something on the last slide
all the randomness that it was
introduced into the system and the
guarantees came from the random
construction of
yours um and it's related to a comment
that that uh yesterday
uh so at the at the end of the day you
have to design a system cheap or person
software so in the real world you you
design something right then you just
hope that uh that the data which is
fixed and you don't know what it is uh
somehow I mean somehow you hope
everything going to be okay right um so
I was wondering if you
know studies or other things in the real
world of how to handle these type of
problems
so
uh I mean I'm not fully sure I this the
question so you're saying that you know
what do we do if you have real data sets
is is is it a one way to Pro face the
question or you mean the real world when
you are forced to design system system
not like a random
one good guarantees on the randomness of
your construction but you have to just
do one Construction oh I see okay no no
no now I
understand uh
so I mean it depends on what is the kind
of you know how much adversity there is
right uh so uh you know in in practice
for many of the things you know you just
pick some Randomness and and you're done
right sometimes this random I mean
sometimes for example for near search
for example rather than picking random
Li people actually in practice do
slightly different that I you know
mention towards the end is that you look
at the data and for example you don't do
random directions but you Partition by
PC for example and um this is even more
dat this is more data independent first
of all right but but then you don't use
as much Randomness right so there are
few answers here you know first you know
just you know pick some Randomness and
hope for the best and you know if your
system does not react adversarially
right then you know most of the time
good you know bad things won't happen
right
um and uh the second answer is um I mean
in some sense at the end in practice
kind of most of the time say okay I it
won't work for you know maybe 5% of the
of the inputs right and this is partly
comes from the from the randomness part
partly comes you know being to data
dependent and you know losing some
guarantees um if if it's more adversary
so in some settings so for example in
this in in streaming for example uh it
can become more
um uh it can become more adversarial and
then the answer sometimes changes a bit
uh so you have to be more careful about
how to use the randomness and maybe
sometimes R randomize but you know for
near s sear you know as far as I know
most of the time kind of people don't
care you know just do it and hope the
best and another question the
other works in which the data is
random uh there has been some but not as
much as one would hope
for uh so so I mean it is a good
question I mean for example for near
search we don't really so there are some
results and I I guess I I actually
skipped from one yeah so for example GRE
valence result I mean it it does give a
much better closest paay well
theoretically at least uh for for
closest pair and you know there it
assumes random point at though you know
the belief here is that for most of this
things I mean in high dimensional
situation random case is more or less
the hard case most of the times so for
near saber search you know even though
we don't have formal proofs but you know
kind my feeling is that in many of the
cases random situation is the hardest
situation where it is close to the
hardest situation so one has to be
careful what it means to be random data
set so from because of that people kind
of more said
well this was part of the motivation to
Define things like doubling Dimension
where you say okay let me try to look at
the data and see if it has additional
properties and you know I I'll prove my
guarantees as a function of these
properties and if it doesn't look like
this say well this is not what I so yeah
usually I mean like it's like there is a
type of kind of type of type of thought
kind of here that I find very convenient
that I mean you Le your algorithm to be
always correct or at least you know in
randomiz sense uh and if it has this
good property for example it has D
diation Lambda then the query time will
be
dependent on this Lambda if it doesn't
satisfy this property the query time
will be
larger so essentially you you always
have the correctness guarantees but you
have this additional guarantees saying
that if your data set is nice also but
you'll actually have a good query time
if it is not as nice you know you might
it might degrade to something
worse yeah yeah and for many algorith
you can do that right and this is cool
so so in some sense it's a stretchable
guarantee right depends on your data set
right but you always guarantee something
test uh there other questions one one
quick last question then we'll break
yeah just want to mention we to use this
great idea in a remote sensing project
about 10 years ago and work quite well
to combine with a support back machine
because want reduce it or sample size
and you can also prove that U when you
have smooth functions in terms of minim
R you don't lose much mhm great yeah
yeah I mean yeah you know the great
things have been applied yeah like I've
seen a number of very nice work that
used that
yeah okay let's thank Alex for the three
hour